okay so hawkeye episode 3 is now out on
disney plus and in this video we're
going to be breaking down all the easter
eggs hidden details callbacks to the
comics and of course giving our review
on the show we're going to be spoiling
it all so if you haven't had a chance to
check it out then i highly recommend
that you check out now if you enjoyed
the video then please hit the thumbs up
button and don't forget to subscribe for
puns that have all the hawkeye fans
quivering without the way i'll stop that
already now let's get into our breakdown
of hawkeye okay so last week's episode
ended with clint taken captive by the
tracksuit mafia in a scene that pulled
directly from the map fraction run
however where things changed up is that
kate bishop dropped in in the worst
rescue attempt ever and she too got
captured it was at this point that we
were introduced to ekko who will be
giving a full comic book breakdown on in
just a bit
who the wh who the hell was that i hope
you're not watching this breakdown
illegally mate now the episode is called
echoes which is of course named after
the villain that we get properly
introduced to in this entry however
going beyond that the description of the
episode talks about how the pair are
facing off against an expanding criminal
conspiracy and i do like how the show is
teasing there's a big bad in the
background as it allows me to do 400
theory videos a week milking it for all
it's worth the show has changed things
up quite a lot from the way that they
are in the comics so i thought i'd talk
about ekko's backstory first from the
source material and then we can discuss
how the episode does things differently
now as for echo in case you missed our
last breakdown where we kind of touched
on her skill set she's basically a mimic
similar to taskmaster however ekko is
actually deaf and she can completely
copy someone's abilities just by
watching them in the comics maya lopez
was the daughter of a hitman named crazy
horse who was murdered by wilson fisk as
he was dying he put his bloody hand
across maya's face and she later adopted
this as one of her symbols in his dying
breath crazy horse asked kingpin to
raise his daughter which he agreed to he
sent her to the best schools and it's
during this time that she watched
someone playing piano and managed to
replicate it completely maya was trained
by the best of the best of the best sir
and in the comics she's gone toe-to-toe
with characters like daredevil at
several points she was actually first
introduced as a love interest for matt
and became one of the toughest people
he's ever faced off against eventually
she discovered that the kingpin had
killed her father and she ended up going
against him which could end up being the
plot of his solo show that we know is
coming down the line ekko is very much
the perfect villain for this series i
think as her father was killed much like
kate's and this led her into a life of
training she's also deaf and clint of
course has a hearing aid so she's a
really good mirror of the both of them i
do think that ekko will end up becoming
somewhat of a good guy at some point and
in the comics she did end up turning
into the ronin at one point the suit is
of course a big focus in the series and
i think it would be awesome if they set
that story up for the future
now in the show we start with a
flashback to 2007 which is where we're
introduced to ekko as a child due to her
deafness she has to lip read but she's
able to mimic the teacher incredibly
well even without an interpreter at home
he watches her and her father play
shadow puppets on the wall subtly
foreshadowing how she can shadow
people's abilities and copy them
completely this scene of her and her
father playing out is of course a mirror
of kate in the first episode and we see
his both characters had a massive impact
on their children's lives mai's father
is played by zan mclarnon who you might
recognize from things like dr sleep and
also westworld he's a great actor and he
brings a lot of heart to this role maya
not only shadow puppets a dragon but she
also brings him up too and asks if
they're real dragons of course exist in
the mcu with them appearing in films
like chongqi however this could also be
a nod to the netflix universe in the
defenders we learned as the hand
organization discovered bones of a
dragon beneath new york city and as maya
as a hand symbol on her face in the
comics it could all be connected i'm not
doing the voice now they also talk about
how dragons could come into our world
which would make them stronger and this
is somewhat mirrored in maya she has to
go to a regular school even though she's
deaf but having to survive in these
surroundings has made her even tougher
we also learn that she has a prosthetic
leg meaning that she's had to adapted
things in more ways than one much like
kaichi's trained in martial arts but
she's someone who has to study people's
body language because she can't rely on
sound and therefore has to read the way
they move it's here that we learn her
dad is part of the tracksuit mafia and
if you slow down the footage you can
actually see some of them leaving as her
father talks to her this explains why
she partners up with them and this is
probably the longest that one of their
members has ever gone without saying bro
now it's at this point that we see a man
come in that touches her face and though
we don't know who this is his clothing
looks very similar to wilson fisk's and
his laugh sounds a lot like vincent
inoffrio's it's clear he's in charge and
he's referred to throughout the episode
as being her uncle this could be a note
of the comic books as in those he was a
father figured a maya so this is a
change-up on that as ekko was much older
when her dad died however her calling
him uncle does make a lot of sense and
it's still this sort of bond because she
called him dad in the comics now i'm
really hoping that kingpin doesn't
become another mephisto but there's a
lot of hints towards him being in the
show including fat man order repair fat
man is something that fisk was referred
to as by the grim reaper so the location
we join myra as an adult could be
teasing towards it here we watch as she
discovers the ronin who wipes out the
mafia including her father he puts a
bloody handprint across her face and
this of course calls back to the moment
that we mentioned earlier we can also
see why ekko was desperate to have clint
and kate left alive and we could have
them being tormented by the mafia i
thought it was absolutely hilarious when
the rides stopped and then the mafia
said they'd go and get more quarters and
clinches goes yes now we also learned
that one of the mafia members has bought
imagine dragon tickets which kate
implies are crap but you know i kind of
like them now as you know we here at the
channel love a good reach and kate
disliking dragons could and it's a big
could be hinting towards how echo loves
them it's here she comes down and i
loved how intimidating having her just
walk in in silence is she's basically
this strong silent type and you can
really feel the power coming through the
screen it's a great introduction and she
realizes that clint is deaf he then
tries to get the mafia off the back of
kate by saying that she simply put on
the suit i love this obsession over it
and i think it would be great if like
the comics she ended up taking on the
mantle the ronin of course killed her
father so her facing after this would
very much be her embracing the darkest
moment of her life it would be
interesting if it turned out that it was
kingpin who tipped clint off to their
whereabouts and that would line up with
the source material i do think that
clint was the one behind it and not
astounding though as he was aware of the
mafia and had clearly had run-ins with
them before clint says black widow
killed the ronin and this could end up
tying into the post-credits scene of
black widow in which val said that
hawkeye killed her i do wonder if this
line will come back around should yelena
show up in the series at some point and
it'll show that they very much covered
for one another black widow in some ways
did kill leronan if we're talking things
from a star wars point of view as she
showed up and got him to stop using the
persona now khasi starts to interrogate
kate and maya loses it and grabs her
which causes a distraction that allows
clint to escape i absolutely love this
scene in the toy store and the only real
toys that we see lying around are dog
ones including golden retrievers which
could be reflecting how pizza dog is
abandoned as well again we do we do do a
bit of reaching here now though i was
disappointed in the first two episodes
this entry really stepped things up a
gear and watching ekko fight shows just
how much of a threat she's gonna be in
the series she knows clint's weakness is
that he's deaf but he's not adjusted
like she is thus she kicks the hearing
aid out of his head and grabs a bow and
arrow to take him on at his own game not
to keep racking on taskmaster but i felt
like this is the way that the character
should have been handled in black widow
the fight scene here is great and
watching kate and clint work together is
what i really wanted to see from the
first two episodes as it's flawless in
this moment now after escaping the
warehouse we get a scene that was pretty
much shown in full during disney plus
day this moment pulls a lot of the
iconography and imagery from the map
fraction run namely the issue that
focuses around clint's girlfriend cherry
in the box after he took over the
apartment block he ended up starting a
rivalry with the mafia and one of the
girlfriends of the group became his this
led to a car chase between them clint
and kate that featured the car we see in
the episode as well as the trick arrows
as they leave the warehouse we see not
only the car from the comics but we can
also see the van behind it which belongs
to the tracksuit mafia the company name
is truster bro which is of course a nod
to how they always say bro bro now there
is some irony with it being a moving van
as well as in the comics they own the
apartment block that clint took over and
made their move out of clint doesn't
want to take the 72 challenger which is
the opposite of the comics in which he
and kate were the ones driving it in
that the mafia rolled around and mini
coopers chasing after them but here they
make off in a car i don't i don't know
what make it is mate more of a comic sky
than a car guy but moving on now in the
comics the group also wore racing
helmets and though they aren't carried
across i think that the scene manages to
capture the feel of the original run
really really well clint ends up asking
kate to drive but he has to do it in the
end even though his deafness stops him
from hearing any replies from her as
they pull out of the parking lot we can
see the building has the same kb toys
above it which just in case you don't
know was an american toy store chain
similar to toys r us bit of trivia there
for my brit heads now they also pass a
u-haul center which i kind of feel like
might be some product placement
especially as u-haul was also advertised
during man of steel now this one shot
chase scene is absolutely incredible and
it's one of my favorite action moments
in a disney plus show so far i
absolutely love when they do one takes
and having it as part of a car chase
just really ticks all the boxes for me
the music in the background we can also
hear is called a mad russian christmas
by the trans siberian orchestra and this
not only ties in with the theme of
christmas but also the mad russians are
now chasing kate and clint now it's at
this point that kate realizes she's
gonna have to shoot but as clint doesn't
have any regular arrows left they have
to break out the trick once if you cast
your mind back to episode 2 then you
might remember that clint denied having
any of these so it's quite funny that
he's backtracked on that and yeah the
guy has got some trick arrows throughout
the mcu movies we've seen as clint has
used a number of these and he even had
one that could hack computers in the
avengers and a usb won in what if which
also pops up here in the comics there
were numerous trick arrows including a
potty one that held people in place
sonic arrows that emitted sound
explosive tip arrows similar to what we
see in the show cable arrows smoke bomb
arrows rocket arrows suction tip arrows
and also boomerang ones and the show
also brings some of these across
including the suction arrow which is
called the plunger one by kate i'm
guessing that this is to clear out the
toilet after nats had a big dump or it
might be used to stick to surfaces like
glass so that he can attach ropes to
buildings and climb up them we do see a
moment in the trailers where clint goes
jumping out the side of a skyscraper so
potentially that arrow could come back
then there's also rope ones acid ones
agatha harkness ones i'm guessing and it
just adds so much to this scene my
favorite is the pymtech one though and
watching this make a giant arrow is
absolutely hilarious now the chase ends
at a bridge and in the comics this fight
was ended by kate unwittingly bringing
out a boomerang arrow one of the mafia
took clint hostage and he told kate to
let it go and she released it being a
boomerang one and then came back around
and took the mafia member out but here
the escape is slightly more daring kate
and clint jump over the side of the
bridge and we see the pair turn around
and fire a grappling arrow that they use
to swing in on top of a train now this
idea of clint jumping over an edge and
then swinging around and shooting his
bow and arrow grappling hook has been
shown in several things that involve the
character it's actually the first panel
in the graphic novel run and going
beyond that the character of course did
it in the avengers that moment was also
the first time that kate saw him and him
saving her life was very inspirational
to her as it's pretty much what made her
become an expert in archery so her doing
this with him is great and it's probably
my favorite shot in the series so far
now on the train the peg get a moment to
rest and behind them we can see that
there is a poster that talks about
family therapy the show itself is very
much centered around the idea of
families as we have kate and her
mother's strained relationship clinton
his kids and also ekko's father and her
uncle there was also jack and armand and
though this poster might not be
intentional i like how it ties into the
overarching themes i think the dialogue
here with the deafness works really
really well and they've managed to use
the humor of the situation to really
lighten the mood however they also use
it to bring the pair together with
really heartfelt moments such as kate
having to relay a message from clinton
nathaniel because he can't hear it you
can see clint wants to be with his kids
but it's super difficult for him because
he's having to support kate as we get
establishing shots of new york we can
also see rogers the musical which so far
has appeared in all of the episodes it
was of course where clint visited in the
first one and it appeared as an advert
in episode 2. i would love it if the
final fight in the season actually took
place at this broadway show and i think
that would be a great location to end it
all at back at moira's apartment the two
recuperate and in case you missed our
last video myra was a character from the
comics that helped to found the west
coast avengers estate we have a much
more in-depth breakdown on her over at
that one so definitely go check it out
right after this now on the other side
of this we see his karzian echo worry
about their uncle finding out and cause
he worked for kingpin in the comics
potentially tying into our big theory
hawkeye and kate have a great back and
forth in the diner after his hearing aid
is fixed and they talk about what being
the cost of a hero is this is something
clint has experienced firsthand and i
loved watching the young up-and-comer
talking to the veteran kate talks to
clint about his branding issue and she
draws a costume for him that's based on
the one from the comics now an easter
egg that was actually cut out last week
came during the larping scene due to a
special featurette that was released
showing behind the scenes stuff we now
know that there was someone who was in
hawkeye's classic costume from the
comics this was cut and now people at
the time were kind of scratching their
heads as to why after seeing the scene
it makes a lot of sense clint says he's
very much not a role model which is why
he's not embracing the branding and
though he has a dark past he dropped
everything in order to save kate the
pair walked the pizza dog and kate calls
carsey the hot guy which could be a nod
to the comics in which the pair dated
they also talk about the mafia and how
there's someone overseeing the entire
operation now one of the big mysteries
surrounding the show at the moment is
who bought the avengers tower i really
hope that it doesn't turn out to be
another aerospace engineer situation
like we had with one division but as
this has been teased at in movies like
homecoming and in episode 5 of loki we
could be getting someone important now
the opening of loki episode 5 teased
that at least in one timeline a kang
variant had bought it as the name keng
did appear on it however last week i was
on the phantom wire podcast agents of
fandom and the host tj said that he
thinks wilson fisk might be the one who
purchased it i absolutely love this
theory i think it would be such a great
twist to have him being behind it all as
it would not only be a big reveal but it
would be a huge gut punch to know that
the villain was now in charge of it
though i've seen mention of norman
osborne being the person who's bought it
i'm not exactly sure what they're doing
with the character in the mcu as no way
home will probably be his first
appearance in the universe now fisk is
laced throughout the episode if you look
closely enough and after deducing that
jack is involved in it somehow they head
to elena's penthouse after hacking
jack's computer several ties to the
mafia come up including karzi's name but
i think at this point he's pretty much a
red herring and that it's eleanor who's
behind it like i'm no sherlock holmes
but yeah my spoiler sense is tingling on
this one they also learn that cause he
is working for sloan limited which could
be a nod to willie sloane an assassin
that worked for kingpin in the comics
there are a lot of characters called
slono and marvel so yeah might not be
him and i'm sure there's someone much
smarter in the comics who's already
figured this all out so let me know
below okay is quickly locked out of the
system and in the apartment jack holds
the ronin sword to clint's neck which
ends the episode in the comics he was a
character known as the swordsman and
both he and hawkeye were friends and
foes at several points i actually think
that he might end up joining them in the
next entry after clint explains where
this sword came from jack clearly
idolizes the ronin so it makes sense to
me that he would actually be an ally to
them and he's of course trying to
impress kate so that's where i can see
things going now as for my thoughts on
the episode i kind of want to address
some comments i got on the last two
videos i did for the show and then we'll
jump into the leaks i said i was a bit
disappointed with the first two episodes
and because of that a number of people
kicked off calling me a hater saying
i've changed and stuff but yeah that's
just how i felt about it there's a this
is weird thing when you talk about
marvel stuff where if you enjoyed it you
get called a shill and if you say you
didn't like something you're
automatically a hater i've talked about
it a lot in the last week and i've said
i thought there were too many filler
elements like the sword fighting the
parties and laughing however there has
been people who've said they've liked
those elements which is absolutely fine
and just in the same way that i like the
eternals because of certain things in it
i know there's people out there that
dislike the movie for the same reasons i
enjoy it it's just kind of weird to me
people can't accept that your opinion
means you like some things and don't
like others and they automatically have
to brand you as being either a shill or
a hater a weird criticism i got was that
people said i didn't like the show
because it wasn't the typical marvel
humor stuff that's full of jokes but
yeah i don't know what you are watching
because
the show definitely has jokes in it
anyway what i'm saying is just let
people enjoy what they enjoy and dislike
what they dislike there's not really an
agenda here and i know there's a very
small section of the fandom i think
everything has to be in black and white
where you either loved it or you hated
it but yeah i was just kind of met on
the whole thing now as for this episode
i thought it was really good so yeah
thumbs up you guys i'm back to being a
shill and i much prefer seeing kate and
clint working together alongside each
other as opposed to how it was where
they went off and kind of did their own
things they've got a really interesting
dynamic relationship and having echo in
this episode really added to it quite a
lot it's weird thinking we're now at the
midpoint of the show and though i've had
criticisms of it i am still enjoying it
even though i probably sound like i'm
moaning a lot so yeah roll on episode
four and if you don't want any of the
spoilers then this is the part where we
say goodbye now as for the leaks on the
show i know i've probably sprung these
on you a bit fast so if you don't want
anything ruined about the upcoming
episodes then i recommend that you turn
off now also if you've enjoyed the video
so far then please give it a thumbs up
and subscribe otherwise you're a sucker
who probably likes other better
breakdowns from other better channels
you idiot what's wrong with you we've
got the top quality stuff here anyway
you might have seen recently that there
was a leaked image of kingpin flowing
around online i don't want to show in
this video in case it's real and i get a
copyright claim for it but it had
vincent and ofrio back as new york's
biggest crime boss however they'd either
put him in a fat suit or made him look
bigger with cgi as the guy was much
larger than we'd ever seen him before
and recent photos of vincent and ofrio
don't look that rotund
yes i said rotund now there was then a
further image released that looked like
the initial ones but it had been
photoshopped and no i'm not showing it
here vincent did debunk it pretty
quickly now i'm still unsure of the
initial ones but you can go and check
out his twitter and you'll see the one
he responded to which does look very
fake leaks are still saying that he will
be in the show and vincent himself has
been teasing things like responding to
the trailer video for the series saying
this is going to be fun personally i do
think that he will be in the series but
if i was guessing i think it'll be more
of a tease towards the end with a focus
being squarely on characters like echo
eleanor and jack for the moment anyway
that's the video and i hope you enjoyed
the breakdown i know it's not a massive
leak but i just thought i'd talk about
that as it's one of the big things
surrounding the show at the moment
either way there are a lot of things to
talk about so make sure you comment
below and let me know your thoughts on
the episode as a thank you you'll be
entered into a competition in which
we're giving away three copies of the
spider-man 4k trilogies on the 30th of
december all you have to do to be with
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of all the spiderman
news we got over the weekend we go over
the teasers tv spots and ticket sales so
it's definitely worth checking out right
after this without the way thank you for
sitting through the video i've been poor
i'll see you in the next one take care
peace